alright guys we are back here on the
GameSpot stage at e3 2014 once again I'm
your host Sean McGuinness and I'm joined
by Ralph Fulton the creative director of
Forza horizon - Ralph thanks a lot for
jumping on the stage with us no no so
great to be here thanks John
cool so you guys announced forts of
horizon 2 pretty recently within the
past couple weeks or so but it was at
the Microsoft press conference that
we've got our first really good look at
the game and it's quite a departure from
the original one you guys are going from
the mountains of Colorado a very
American you know
Rocky Mountain kind of setting and
you're taking it across the Atlantic all
the way to southern Europe and this is
something that we talked about the other
night but was the reason behind moving
it to southern Europe that sort of
Mediterranean coast kind of setting so
yeah you're absolutely right I loved
Colorado in the first game and get
incredible setting and when we started
looking at this game we were like okay
where where can we find in the world and
we looked the whole world over that had
the same things and maybe even more
right so we looked all over the world we
had a bunch of criteria that we
absolutely needed to hit we wanted
somewhere that was just stunningly
beautiful really diverse varied
interesting locations that people really
want to explore and I guess the
interesting thing is when we first
looked at the original horizon both the
south of France and the north of Italy
scored really highly not as highly as
Colorado distant we went with that right
but this time on xbox one we're able to
have this bigger world so we we looked
back at our scoring and our criteria we
throw a net over that whole region that
whole Mediterranean coastal region and
it really checked all our boxes so we
said let's let's go to Europe let's
bring the horizon first of all to Europe
cool let's talk about the festival
itself obviously that was a sort of a
key aspect of the original game the hub
from which you would sort of explore
outward toward the rest of the world
how does it what's its role in the
second game yes so the horizon festival
I guess has expanded since the first
game is has branched out overseas it's
come to Europe which is in many ways the
spiritual home of the great music
festivals and it's still the centrepiece
of the game and it represents for us the
the combination of awesome cars and car
culture and
so festival culture and music which is
an incredibly important part of the
horizon game as well it brings them both
together and it's the place you'll go to
right at the start of the game
that's your first trip to the road to
the festival but beyond that you're
gonna go out on a road trip
you're gonna go out much longer journeys
from destination to destination
competing in championships exploring
finding things on the way and at the end
of a road trip you'll look back to the
festival for a big awards party where
all the all the characters in the game
or the drive Attar's are rewarded for
how they've done and the championships
that one alright now with the original
Forza horizon you guys dabbled in a
little bit of light storytelling you had
some characters involved there what's
your approach to that this time is it
how does it compare with that original
Forza horizon so horizon 2 uses Drive
attire technology that I just mentioned
first launched in Forza 5 last year and
for me it just changed racing right no
longer do you have to have fictional
drivers with made-up names suddenly your
races and your world now horizon 2 is
filled with real people your friends
your family people that you can relate
to in the real world so we've actually
found in horizon 2 we don't need to tell
a story we don't need to have fictional
characters to make up the game because
actually the driver tires do all that
heavy lifting for us there are people
that you already know you can relate to
the way they drive the things that they
do and it actually makes the narrative
all about you all about your friends
which i think is much more compelling
and if it's turn 10 community manager
Brian Ekberg I know that character is
gonna drive like a total maniac and it's
totally gonna cut me off at the most
inopportune moments of a critical race
absolutely and you know what's really
cool for me about Drive attire is the
way an element of racing games which
maybe hasn't moved on for very for many
years suddenly is something you talk
about outside the game right you and
Brian will talk about the things that
his drivers are dead or your driver tart
that the same thing happens to me people
tweet me about the things my driver
tires doing in races in Forza 5 I think
we're gonna find that with horizon 2 you
know these these are events become water
cooler moments so we had a question here
about the soundtrack I forget who that
was but music you know the whole
festival was obviously a pretty big
party there is
Oh game yeah did just the vibe of the
overall soundtrack and the and the
licensed song does that change with the
setting moving from Colorado to Southern
Europe or is it kind of the overall tone
gonna stay the same so we're excited
about the music in horizon 2 I think we
did a great job in the first one more
people tweet me about the soundtrack and
horizon 1 than about any other aspect of
the game so our strategy for this game
is just to keep doing it more and more
right so the guy who created the
soundtrack in the first one robbed a
bank he's this English DJ festival
organizer he's back on board he's
curated the soundtrack for horizon 2 and
we've just given him more room to
express himself so we have twice as many
radio stations more than double the
amount of music on desk so we're
actually bringing you more and more
music more diversity we really hope that
you're gonna find songs you love but
you're also gonna fall in love with new
music as well so there's this moment
that we just saw in the footage here and
it's about 30 seconds past but you're
driving along the road and you're a
green driving line all of a sudden cuts
to the left and into this big open field
I don't know it's maybe a vineyard or
something like that but basically it's
one of those moments where I was playing
for the first time I was like wait this
can't be right this can't be right what
am i doing I can barely see I'm in a cog
for that view what's going on here I'm
just smashing into hay bales but it
seems like you know getting off the road
and kind of taking advantage of the
openness of an open world it's kind of a
focus for you guys right absolutely
absolutely we wanted to create a truly
open world this time you know we've
taken the view that if there are if
there aren't walls or barriers in real
life well there shouldn't be then
barriers are wolves in our game right we
want you to be able to drive on the road
we want you to be able to explore
anywhere off the road as well so what
you're talking about driving through a
vineyard we're in southern Tuscany here
so there's loss of any yards there are
across crop fields through forests
silver hills it's a whole new dimension
to exploration and driving with a
horizon too what it means is we've
actually got so much more space to fill
with cool stuff to do in cars right I'm
talking about races I'm talking about
non recent game plays well challenges
secrets and things to discover now how
do you balance those
sort of like crazy detours with the fact
that quite often you're gonna be driving
a McLaren p1 or a really really fancy
sports car that was designed to be
driven on the road yeah absolutely so
throughout the game I think there's a
there's a risk/reward thing going on
there right depending on the car you're
in sometimes it could be faster to stay
on the tarmac you know if you're in a
really high speed performance car
sometimes though if you're in an
off-roader a Ford Raptor or some of the
really extreme cars we've got in the
game it will pay to go off-road but
ultimately horizon the hope the whole
all-out franchise is about having fun
doing things which maybe aren't things
you would do in real life but things
which are just crazy fun and sometimes
driving across farmlands you know
through crop fields and a Lamborghini
Huracan it's just crazy fun and we
wanted to encourage you to do that and
we've got about a minute or two left
here but I would be just absolutely
trounced by our hardcore racing fans in
the audience if I didn't talk to you on
some level about just you know the
physics of the driving model obviously
your connection to Forza Motorsport
lends itself to any number of questions
about the simulation nature of what
you're trying to go for here the
original game you had all but a whole
bunch of driving assist that you could
toggle on to make the game pretty
hardcore but at the same time you you
didn't drill down into the really
esoteric stuff gear ratios and all that
what's your approach this time around so
a couple of things here so we start from
the starting point of having parts of
motorsport 5s engine that's where we
started from with all commented that
we've enhanced it in lots of different
ways but at its core we have that same
physics system phase physics simulation
that you seen for us a five it still
runs at three hundred and sixty Hertz
you know so there's incredible
complexity and sophistication and that
physics emulation a couple of things we
do first of all because we're driving in
an open world and the way you drive in
an open world is different from how you
drag on Laguna Seca or Nurburgring right
so I guess we rear-end off the edges of
some of the difficulty in that
simulation while still having the
complexity underlying it but we've
listened to our fans from the first game
a lot of guys said hey I want to tune my
car I want to be able to play with the
suspension with the gear ratios so we
brought that back before it's horizon to
horizon - you can upgrade your car
cosmetically in terms of engine parts
but you can also tune it in exactly the
same way you would import some
motorsport 5 so I I hope people are
going to be excited to experiment with
that
in September all right Ralph sounds
great I had a lot of fun playing it the
other night I'm probably going to try to
sneak over there again at some point -
be my guest all right thanks a lot for
joining us on the stage thanks Sean